Jamais ce produit n'a été autant convoité.
Le papier toilette en rouleau
a été inventé aux Etats-Unis à la fin du XIXe siècle.
C'est la bande perforée qui a fait son succès.
Il n'est arrivé en France qu'au début des années 1960
en remplacement du papier journal.
Sans entrer dans les détails son succès tient également à sa capacité d'absorption
qui elle-même est liée au phénomène de capillarité.
Le papier toilette est constitué
de fibres de cellulose entremêlées.
Les molécules qui la composent
et les molécules d'eau s'attirent mutuellement.
Du coup, l'eau remonte entre les fibres.
*bruitage*
Comme le café dans un morceau de sucre.
Vous voyez le papier toilette
c'est hygiénique et physique
et c'est une vraie "capsule de déconfiné"
Allez à demain et surtout n'oubliez pas :
on est confiné mais en reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors, pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné" :
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain !